[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] [Applause]
[Music]
adc is fast approaching which means it
starts it's time to start thinking about
fashion hair makeup i know i am jillian
joins us live from dry bar at the
district at green valley ranch with edc
hairstyle inspiration
hey guys so yes we are getting ready for
edc and you know it's long nights ahead
of you you want your hair your makeup
everything to stay in place and look
good so i'm here at the dry bar at the
district at green valley ranch i'm
joined by xena thank you so much for
having us we're getting ready for edc
let's talk about what you guys offer
here at the dry bar we offer any type of
signature styles we have five different
signature styles for
blow dries updos half updos we offer
braids we also offer conditioning
treatments and um
just a lot of fun yes i absolutely love
drybar you guys really you feel like
you're on vacation when you get to come
in get your hair washed looking good
tell us a little bit about what we have
here and then i'll hand the mic over to
rakaira but um this is inspired by one
of your traditional dry bar looks right
yes this is our signature style the mai
tai which is beachy waves and then she
just threw a couple braids in there with
the space buns for the edc look keep
your hair up out of your face have a lot
of fun yeah it's going to be hot out
there so it's nice to have a little bit
of a pullback here and rakaiora how long
would something like this take if you
come in from start to finish this will
have longevity and this will last you
all night through edc and you're just
doing a braid
tell me a little bit more about what we
have here because i am loving this look
so the braid is a little something with
its pull back which will add longevity
especially when it's hot out you'll be
able to sweat and last all day well you
look beautiful you're inspiring me i'm
not going to edc but now i want to go to
edc and you guys have dry bar locations
all around las vegas can people just
walk in do you require appointments how
does it work you can just walk in
however we are super busy this weekend
so we do advise booking ahead of time
however we'll always try to make
anything work if you walk in so you can
call the shop directly or you can book
online and do you handle all types of
hair are there any limitations how does
all that work we handle all types of
hair up to for heat up to 450 we do
washes and styles only
no cuts no colors just blowouts and
we also have a really fantastic
experience on the strip with you know
djs and
bars yeah a lot going on and my biggest
question is you know when you go in to
get your hair done and you're like oh
it's a little dirty am i embarrassed to
come in do you recommend coming in with
dirty hair do you wash everything take
me through the process oh we love dirty
hair if you come in we give you the wash
it's one of the best
parts of the service everybody loves the
wash so we give you the wash we also
blow dry your hair and any style with a
curling iron or flat iron is also
included in our price well it's the
ultimate experience here at dry bar so
be sure to come down check them out
they're located at the district you
can't miss them like i said i'm inspired
i want to go to edc now you look
beautiful give us a little opposed to
the camera here thank you guys i'll send
it back to you
all right jillian we'll check back with
you later this hour edc is also taking
part or taking over nightclubs i should
say and and this is the part of the show
where i read off a list of artists my
kids would know but i only hope to
pronounce correctly hakkasan will have
alesso taiga and loud luxury over at
omni nightclub illinium will be back
along with martin garrix and armin van
buren and zuck at resorts world which i
just went to by the way but not as a
club there was a different event there
they're gonna have dead mouse and g-eazy